taiwan walk off to a very good start
cloudy skies we had some rain earlier
this morning but we've got baseball
ferendo the rbi leader in the major
leagues last year
jp a little wide but nice footwork as
always evan white down in first the one
two three first good inning for taiwan
walker dylan bundy's on the bump this
will be his third start
off speed got him good off speed pitch
real good arm action on his change up
that's 17 of his pitches this year has
been his change-up here's shohei ohtani
shohei shooting one out to left field
has some carry d gord moving back near
the wall gone
big fly otanisa
one nothing halos ohtani the opposite
way
dee gordon was jumping up at the wall
and that one got over the wall ohtani's
third home run of the season is justin
upton
seeger's gonna charge this one glove
throw footwork again by evan white
shall we dance man that kid is good over
there max dassey the catcher for the
angels leads it off swag in a miss big
fastball third
for taiwan he struck at three of the
last four and here you go another
fastball up out of the strike zone gets
him to chase it
here's david fletcher
shed long charges nice nice play to
retire
david fletcher taiwan after the home
runs retired the next six minutes bundy
comes home with a pitch
got him looking they'll back up breaking
ball two outs third strike gallon for
dylan first strikeout on a slider now he
got a couple of those strikeouts as well
on elevated sliders that back up one
got him with a breaking ball stassi has
to throw down to first base and he'll
complete the strikeout with the throttle
estella we head to the fourth inning
runners on it first and second with
nobody out here in the top of the fourth
and that'll bring up designated hitter
shohei ohtani 3-0 the count on ohtani
the next pitch on the way and that's up
and away for ball four so ohtani draws a
walk and that'll bring up first baseman
tommy la stella and field back and it's
pulled and into right field of base hit
travel score rendezvous stopped at third
it's two nothing angels that'll bring up
left fielder justin upton
let's say it got him yeah they did three
nothing it just went away from him too
all of a sudden mcstacy coming to the
plate
that's hit well out to right field dylan
moore moving back onto the track he'll
make the catch tagging and scoring as
ohtani sacrifice fly makes it four
nothing here is designated hitter daniel
vogelbach
bogey gets into one and that's his first
home run of the season
i was just pulling out the paper to see
what his last one was he was so so dude
this is a change up 82 miles an hour but
it's up in the zone one of the few
mistakes that bunny has made with that
pit alex smith leads things off
co2 to malek swing and a miss
for strike three another strikeout for
dylan bundy his fifth and there's one
out for the mariners here in the bottom
of any number five bundy hasn't walked
any there's a fastball that is lined
over to the third baseman and it's held
on to you by rendon so
hudson hit it hard but right at rindo
what a play by rendon showing some hops
i know he's a big basketball fan
dylan bundy he's been flashing the
breaking ball this entire game
got him looking down goes more
21 strikeouts two walks
in his career as an angel for dylan but
bogelbach one for two
got a fastball this is lifted out to
shallow left field fletcher going out
calls everybody off in a one two three
sixth inning for dylan bundy dylan
bundy's been in control one two pitch
and look they went around he did home
plate umpire gabe morales called it out
there it is again three of them above
the hands
there's max
as far as anybody winning or running
away never know stassi did he do it
again he did
max statsy look at the bullpen
[Applause]
he's got the standing over maximus
on an 02 count
two run big fly the angels had some
insurance it's six to one here in the
eighth we begin the bottom of the ninth
inning dylan bundy will stay in the game
bundy looks in ready the wind-up and the
3-2 pitch swing and a miss for strike
three
and that is strikeout number 10 for
dylan bundy this afternoon 0-2 pitch
fastball hits sharply to the right side
off of ring heaven to fletcher onto
first just like they designed it 4-6-3
for the out this ball was rocketed from
bogelbach
liner
at the top of the glove but fletch he is
everywhere
so back toward the middle fletcher has
it light that baby up as the angels pick
up the victory today by the final of six
to one cg for
dylan bundy went out there in his third
career
complete game
outstanding effort